[Music]
it is time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share items that might help
make your day a little bit better all at
exclusive low prices you've got
discounts here to start shopping now
scan the QR code on your screen you can
see it there on the upper left or visit
cbsdeals.com Candy Carter Chief content
officer for the e-commerce company
knocking joins us now candy so great to
have you here
okay everybody at home go to
cbsdeals.com right now so we can all
shop together just in time for the
season of weddings and the good weather
we've got something to make memories
last okay first of all I have the
biggest surprise for the three of you oh
okay Vlad what oh wait yeah look at that
these are heirloom books these are video
memory books Oh no just hold it just oh
just hold it just open it look at it
look at that super easy open it just
open it okay
that's absolutely correct because I'm
like in my book it's a high quality
video you send your videos
choose different covers you have an
instruction flat in the front of your
book your wife sent us photos some
videos that she put she was acting real
fishy together yes
um
show him the picture we have a picture
that your wife sent in these are brutal
look at that
I am obsessed with these socks somebody
told me about these six months ago these
are no show look I'm wearing them no
show socks okay they don't slide let me
say it again that's the key not slide
you walk five feet in regular ones the
socks under your feet this is actually a
very good idea I love it looks because
it's Square on the top that's why they
don't slide they don't show 9.99 to
41.99 get the five pack I wear eight and
a half ladies I wear a medium my
husband's in 11 he wears a large okay I
wear a ten so one of my large I would
try
neck neck wrap I didn't know you have to
change your pillow out more than once
every eight years that's right yeah so I
woke up my neck was killing me I keep
this in my bathroom all right I'm gonna
put this on your neck it heats up in
less than two minutes it's got three
settings right vibrate heat and what's
great about it it's weighted so it lays
right here on your neck and so my neck
was killing me and that heat kicked
right in it felt better really awesome
and I took it on the plane the next day
and wore it on the plane so less than 25
dollars a massage would be 150 bucks at
Starbucks it's real warm and it's real
it's really great okay slide over okay
last one it is Autism Awareness Month yo
you know I have a summer special yes
Emerson is 20 today wow two moms Pat and
Pam started beloved bath because they
have kids with autism right when our
kids get out of high school which is my
son next year I don't know what he's
gonna do they employ adults with autism
they can come and they can work there I
went to visit I saw the kids working it
was amazing these products are great
they're lavender body butter
um calming soy candles and the Soaps so
for 38.50 you guys can support these
moms during Autism Awareness Month and
for parents like me they're a godsend
and I'm so grateful this is shopping
with such a good variety of candy today
yeah very nice yeah it's all great this
is going to go you got to get the coffee
machine because it's cheap right so it's
like but they're so good I mean it
really works I had on yesterday actually
and when I tell you I've told everybody
to buy these socks I'm not even kidding
you normally what I do is you wear pads
they show or I take socks and try to
roll them down the game is everything
kids in their shorts right yep these
shoes Yep this is 38.50 stop for good
let's support these Founders they're
amazing but this is really where it's at
I think you know all day
life on camera I made these for my
daughter for Camp no more she's getting
an heirloom book and put it in her
luggage and this is a great side yes
thank you Candy Corner pleasure to have
you here
thank you very much of course we do
partner with all these companies to get
these deals if you want to buy anything
you saw today and I know you do all you
gotta do is scan the QR code on your
screen there upper left or head to
cbsdeals.com to start shopping now we'll
be right back do you recharge